all right guys
bang bang i've got will here what's
going on man
not much pump just uh you know a lot
going on this week
in the market so trying to keep up with
everything absolutely i think people are
really really enjoying these uh
kind of overviews on chain metrics so
let's just jump right into uh
what we're seeing this week it feels
like um you know
price is uh kind of just oscillating
back and forth between that like thirty
thousand thirty five thousand
what are you seeing yeah um
you know in terms of of price that
hasn't been so pretty i think in a lot
of the the ti
i'm sorry the ta guys are calling for um
lower prices i think
you know um what we've been describing
is is still just kind of
continued uh in terms of the
accumulation that we've been describing
um so that was kind of a you know a
broader theme of what was in this
week's newsletter but uh yeah i think
you know price has kind of been um
decoupling from from what the kind of
fundamental you know investment behavior
is showing
um and you know perhaps you know this
still is like we've been saying it's
just going to take out a little bit
take a little bit longer than we had
initially expected um
but i still don't see any changes and
kind of the re-accumulation that we've
been describing
absolutely and it feels like really uh
the the big big takeaway here
is uh people are selling price has been
going down
but strong hands the experienced market
participants they're just
gobbling up all this bitcoin uh and one
of the things that you wrote about was
the illiquid supply chain metric so
maybe talk about just remind everyone
what that metric is and then what you're
seeing in it
yeah so you know this is a metric i
think we've had in for the last
um two weeks um and it basically looks
at the 30-day
change between um a liquid supply so
um the way you can think of this is you
know willy woo calls it the the rick
astley indicator
i kind of call it like the strong hands
indicator it's showing
um you know entities that have held
bitcoin for
over 155 days but have statistically
very
low selling behavior and so we're
starting to see
um you know that continued trend of
supply moving to those entities
um on monday uh this got up to the
30-day change got up to
95 800 so yeah still seeing a
continuation of that trend
um and then kind of like going off of
that um
i had i've been working with willy woo a
little bit um we've been kind of in
touch over the last
couple weeks um but we put together
something called the the liquid supply
ratio which is
pretty much just a variant of that a
liquid supply metric
and so this is just a very simple ratio
of liquid supply to a liquid supply
and so what you see in this you know
when i presented the idea to willie and
he he charted it out
um and so he messaged me he's like you
know this is really interesting
um you look at the ratio and it's it's
showing what's called
a bullish divergence um which the
oscillator is making
higher lows while price is of course
making lower lows lately
but what that's showing is that you know
strong hands are increasingly
buying the dip you know more so more so
as we continue to go lower but but
prices is making lower lows but this is
like the
most i would say most clear divergence
that we've had since
that big correction we had in late
january or early march
i mean i'm sorry early february got it
and then when you look at who the
selling is coming from if the strong
experienced hands are
uh buying up the bitcoin is all the
selling coming from the young entities
yep um and you know this has been going
on for you know
a month now we've been talking about how
you know all the selling is coming from
shorter term market participants i'm
actually taking a look this morning at
this
chart which actually wasn't in the
newsletter but it's called um newpol but
it's a dish
looking at short-term entities and that
that's in
like a deep capitulation as of yesterday
so
um and and as well looking at sober
which is something that we talked about
on the short term
time frame that that's showing
capitulation as well
especially from from short-term holders
um i actually just put something out
kind of comparing
um you know the long short-term holders
over the last month
um in the last 30 days long-term holders
have added 579
9440 btc while short-term holders have
reduced their holdings by 521
983 btc so you have this offset now of
longer-term holders out buying the
selling from the short-term holders
in the last week these long-term holders
have added 120
000 um 739 btc while short-term holders
have reduced their holdings
by 97th out just over 97 000 btc
so you have this offset of over the last
week um
long-term well this is at the time of
writing it might be a little off out the
day after but
longer term holders are are offsetting
the short term selling by over 20 000
btc
um and you know this is something that
we've talked about before but you know
either
this resembles um a few things so you
know
after after the end of the bull market
um so you know
late late 2018 or late 2017 early 2018
um and then obviously after the 2013
bull market as well but then it also
resembles kind of this mid consolidation
which you know took place in mid 2013
and then also
kind of this divergence you had in
late uh 2016 where you had you know the
the longer term holders coming in
and setting the floor um while some of
those shortage room speculators uh
you know freaked out moved out of the
market so that
you know those are the those are the
other times where we've seen this
divergence between
the short and long term holders but this
has been something we've tracked and
been tracking for a while now and you
know
i think the key takeaway here is for
anybody that's that's in this asset you
know
for the long term when you're looking at
people who have been in this market
you know they're they're stepping in
here and saying the count
bitcoin is you know a good deal right
now and um they're they're stacking
really heavily
well the shorter term market
participants you know the speculators
are
starting to get freaked out and moving
out which um you know
it's great long term perhaps you know
this isn't
very great in in you know the very short
term because
you need um i think you know some of
those those newer
speculators to come in and that's kind
of what um drives the
euphoric price runs we see um and so
that's that's
why you know we we've seen this you know
price correction and
this you know what i believe to be a a
broader uh kind of consolidation
um but yeah i i you you see a lot of um
capitulation from the from these short
holders
yeah and it looks like one of the most
fascinating parts of your analysis this
week
is the new entity growth is exploding
there's tons and tons of uh kind of new
participants coming into the market we
don't know exactly who they are or where
they're coming from
but they don't appear to be whales these
are all much much smaller
so it's almost like aggregate growth of
total new users
is exploding upwards uh but they tend to
be smaller rather than larger players at
the moment
yeah exactly um and so you know this
metrics called um end of these net
growth it's like very technical term i
think
i would rename it you know net user
growth i think that would
um make it make a lot more sense for you
know people
that you know hadn't seen it before uh
but so essentially what this is is it's
looking at you know
new entities coming on the blockchain
and then subtracting
those entities that number from the
amount that
or the addresses that seem to be dormant
the the entities that seem to be dormant
um and also sorry put that around so the
subtracting the entities that look like
they're dormant from the from the new
entities
and then you get the net growth right um
and so
you're seeing this big w shape for
anybody like looking at the newsletter
like it's literally a w
big w on the chart but
i think a lot of this like you said is
retail
because first of all you know we're not
seeing that uptick in new whales which
is
um something i believe that we're going
to need to see if we have any kind of
you know large broader bull market
continuation from here
um but also when you just look at the uh
the raw holdings by you know by by the
size of of the entity so you know
perhaps you know you can look at below
one btc
below five btc wherever you want to call
that cut off for retail um
i would say you know anything below
maybe maybe 10 btc
i think you know that's below you know
310
10 000 i think you know they consider
consider that still retail investor
but you know all those all the smaller
entities particularly
the very smallest ones under one btc and
below that
they're all stacking very very heavily
you know you see this chart
is basically just going vertical in
terms of the amount of supply that's
being held by them
and meanwhile you know you aren't seeing
this uptick in new whales so i think a
lot of this
new user growth is uh you know
new retail um you know smaller holders
and which of course is bullish for
bitcoin adoption but you know not price
in the short term
um i think it would be interesting to
see how many of these new users are
coming from latin america because i
highly suspect that a lot of the
a lot of this uh big uptick is coming
from them
absolutely well any time that you see uh
kind of headlines right in a certain
geography uh it's basically a marketing
campaign for a future acquisition
uh we see this in the traditional world
even things like robin hood right where
uh there was tons and tons of issues
with their app they shut down the
service everyone's yelling and screaming
they actually gained users during that
period even though people were kind of
yelling at them and so
it's kind of the streisand effect and
i'm assuming that's happening here in
latin america as well
let's move on to uh sopra i feel like
every week everyone wants to know what
is going on with sopra so what uh what
do you see in there
yeah um sober was interesting so at the
time that i wrote this um
we saw this big high or low in soper um
so
i put in the letter that it was a it was
a big bullish divergence where you know
the oscillator is making a higher low
price is making lower low and the last
time we had seen a big
divergence like that was once again in
late january but
actually checking it when i woke up this
morning there's a big draw down
in sober yesterday and particularly you
know breaking that down between
um you know long-term and short-term
entities
um that that the gist of it um is coming
from the short-term holder so
it seemed like yesterday we had a lot of
capitulation because
these metrics are updated at 8 30 every
every night my time eastern time
so it seemed like yesterday we had a lot
of capitulation from the short-term
holders and
that bullish divergence that i had put
in the newsletter it is now invalidated
because
we no longer have that have that high or
low so
hey guys what's going on before we
continue with this awesome episode i
want to quickly talk about our sponsor
kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as 10
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app
you'll have your portfolio in your
pocket you can track your portfolio
see who the winners and losers are every
day track your favorite project or just
simply look at the trading volume for
your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more or go to your favorite app store
and simply search the word kraken and
you can download the mobile app there
crackit's been a long time supporter of
this show so to say thanks it would mean
the world to me if you would go
and download their new mobile app all
right let's get back into this episode i
hope you're enjoying this one
it's fascinating to watch this stuff
literally change uh you know in 12 hours
24 hours
um so aggressively glass node's got this
new metric a
stable coin supply ratio oscillator uh
explain a little bit about what this
metric is kind of really getting at and
then kind of what you're reading in the
uh in the metric itself
yeah so you know this was a metric
created by willy woo
that glassdog had just recently put in
there um the way you can think of this
is just like
um the amount of the amount of stable
coins that are kind of sitting on the
sideline versus you know like
are they moving back into the market or
not and so you see right now we're kind
of moving out of this zone that
previously has kind of marked this big
bottom capitulation bottom
and you're you know you're now starting
to see some of that capital rotate back
into the market
uh and so you know we we've only had
stable coins for
um you know the latter half of bitcoin's
existence so the chart only goes back to
um late 2018 but the the other times
that this resembles you know
the the drawdown in the oscillator and
you know
us moving back up out of this out of a
you know zone that we're in
um it also resembles um late 2018
the the march uh the big march crash we
had last year and then also
on that that late september drawdown
that we had right before you know the
big
run-up um at the end of last year as
well so yeah
we're starting to see you know we've
been talking about for a while for a few
weeks that you know we had a lot of
stable coins that were just kind of
sitting on the sidelines right
and um we hadn't seen them necessarily
move back into the market but they were
there
perhaps you know just waiting for a
better entry point but
we are you know as of this week starting
to see um that capital in the in the
form of stable coins start to rotate
back into the market which is
you know a good sign of recovery for
sure um one of the charts that to me
is like just hitting us over the head
and how obvious
um there was a change in early june is
this minor net position change
and i think that right around that time
is when the crackdown on miners in china
started
so maybe talk a little bit about what
you're seeing there with uh with miners
and kind of what they're doing
yeah this is this is interesting so um
well first of all like when you just
look at the hash rate
um you know hash rate's pretty much just
dropped off a cliff we're now at the
lowest point that we've been in
in terms of like daily average hash rate
um
in over a year so yeah you can
definitely see um
in the data that i'm looking at um that
you know a lot of that hash rate is is
migrating out from china
and has temporarily been taken off the
network of course we have you know
a uh the difficulty adjustment coming up
right around july 1st
um so that'll be that'll be great when
that finally occurs but for now yeah
we're
we're stuck with you know a lot of loss
of hash rate and difficulty hasn't
adjusted yet but
um in terms of like the the raw holdings
of miners
um i think this is interesting because a
lot of
um a lot of the song has been believed
to have come from minors um but
what i'm saying and at least the data
that i'm looking at is
not not so much because they've reduced
their their balance by you know just
over 5000 bitcoins so
5125 at the time of rating i think it
might be
up by like 50 btc or something since i
wrote this two days ago
but yeah it's i mean they are selling
like right like they are reducing um
their holdings but
not um on any magnitude that would have
you know significant impact on on price
because you know the market can absorb
5000 btc with
with really no problem unless it's you
know sold in a very short period of time
but
uh you know it's not anything that i
think i don't think
um the the miners themselves are
responsible for this drawdown and in
terms of you know just looking
at how many bitcoins have been sent out
of their wallets to exchanges
presumably to be sold so they're
definitely selling though but just not
and what i'm looking at on any extent
that's going to draw the market down to
30k for sure
uh before we let you go you've got a new
metric
uh that you created um you've currently
titled it the otc
desk outflow stock rsi
signal which is a horrible mouthful you
know that that's a horrible name
i think uh we got a recommendation from
somebody that we should just call it the
clemente signal
i don't know if you want to do that or
not we'll leave that up to you but
talk a little bit about this brand new
uh kind of signal that you've created
and what exactly you're trying to look
for in it and what it's telling us right
now
yeah so i think you know when you're in
a market like this
um the you know the money that's really
pushing the market around is
you know the big money right um so i i
was thinking you know kind of from first
principles of how can i track
you know that that big money and so i
was like okay
well big money goes through otc desks
right um
most of the most of the entities going
through otc desks are like high net
worth individuals
institutionals those those kinds of
entities so
um i looked at you know the otc outflows
um
and and when you when you just look at
that chart itself it's very noisy you
see up down on up down up down
it almost looks like you know when
you're looking at like a chart of like a
someone's heartbeat when it's like going
crazy there's really
you can't really draw any major signal
out of that um
and so what i did was you know glass
note has just uh
added they have this tab on the top um
where it says trading view and you can
you can use different indicators
basically um adding you know traditional
ta indicators to
some of these on-chain metrics which um
shout out to raphael because you know
this is this is pretty sick i've been
playing around with this all week
they just added this in so when you i
added a stock rsi um to this which
basically looks at the strength of the
metric
and so when you when you plot this out
um
you you get you know kind of this range
that
bitcoin you know the the metric trades
in
um usually but then when you have um a
breakout to the upside it's a it's a buy
indicator because it's showing that
there's
really strong um the trend of otc
outflows is really strong
and then conversely when it breaks out
to the bottom of this range
it's been it's been a cell indicator and
so you know that's showing that
there's not many otc outflows aka
there's there's not a lot of
you know high net worth institutional
buying going on okay you know big money
so you see you know it's it's been um
a little over 90 accurate um aside from
one missed uh
buy signal but and this is just back
tested over over the last year to be
honest i haven't back tested
it over like the previous bull market
this is just over the last year
um so that 90 number might be give or
take but um
yeah over the last year it's it's been
very accurate um
you know it's timed right before the the
buy right before we had that run up in
september
um you know several buy indicators on
the way on the way up
and then it flashed another buy signal
after the january capitulation
and actually um timed the one of the
tops and marched really well like
almost to the tick um timed the you know
the the dip we had after that
another dip in in late april and then it
also flashed a big uh sell signal right
before we had that initial big draw down
to 30k
so you know if you were using this
indicator and going off of this then you
know
you would have been in good shape if you
had if you had sold right before um you
know we had that big drawdown when it
flashed this sell signal so
um interesting it it it just flashed um
a buy signal which
we'll see how that plays out um you know
over the next few weeks but
uh yeah this is i'm trying to i'm trying
to play around with some with some new
stuff because
glossner just added this uh this trading
view tab where you can kind of create
your own metrics
um so yeah this is the first one i've
come up with hopefully i have some
new stuff for the audience over the next
few weeks
it's awesome i think you're doing a a
fantastic job before i let you go
uh where can we send people to find you
on twitter or or find out the newsletter
yeah so um i have um i'm gonna get a url
for this so i don't have to
to say this mouthful every time but uh
on my sub stack it's uh
btc by wc3 dot substack.com and then
like i just said i'm gonna try to get a
url so you don't have to type in all
that and you can just type in something
quick and just get right to it
recommended by pomp so yeah you can find
me on there on twitter
all day long you know just put out stuff
whatever i find interesting or
you know if you tweet at me i'll you
know engage with you whatever i'm just
you know on twitter hanging out so feel
free to reach out
dms are open all that so awesome man
well listen
i think uh the the big takeaway from
this week is you know
all the short-term market participants
they're selling uh
the long-term experience strong hands
they're buying
uh there's tons and tons of insights in
uh
nissan chain metrics so i appreciate you
spending so much time into the audiences
as well
in terms of breaking this stuff down it
definitely kind of
provides some signal inside of all the
noise and the sentiment because
you know twitter twitter was not very
happy there's a lot of people very very
bearish
on on twitter over the last couple of
weeks so uh keep at it and then we'll do
this again next weekend
thanks pomp yeah i think you know a lot
of people freaking out i think maybe
this is their first rodeo